Game of Thrones Season seven episode 6
begins with our fellowship of heroes
beyond the wall there's a bit of a
culture clash between John and Gendry
and torment Gendry is from the south
while John is from the north and tormund
as a wildling is from the lands beyond
the wall north of the north to him
John's north is the south it's relative
so maybe the white walkers who come from
the far north lands of always winter who
would consider even the wildling lands
as south
Gendry is mad at barrack and Thoros
because in season three they sold Gendry
to Melisandre who used him in a blood
magic ritual Gendry describes Mill
having sex with him and the Hound tells
him to stop whingeing kendrys experience
with mel was what you might call a rape
Gendry was Mel's prisoner and she
pressured him into sex that he had no
option to refuse but the story brushes
this off as no big deal and so did most
of the viewers compare that to the rape
of Sansa by Ramsay Bolton which was
similar in that Ramsay had power of a
Sansa and pressured her into sex without
her consent there is a difference in a
trauma Sansa felt here compared to
kendrys more relaxed response but the
fact that the Sansa scene caused such
widespread media outrage while Gendry
scene was mostly ignored might say
something about how our society views
gender and sex John and Jorah talk about
Joris father Joe who was killed by
Nights Watch mutineers in season 3 Jorah
says it's a horrible way for Joe to die
and John agrees which is kind of funny
because he died the same way
betrayed by his brothers at the watch
Joe gave the Mormont family sword along
claw to John in season one because Jorah
had shamed the family by slaving John
now tries to give the sword to Jorah but
he refuses and says John should keep it
it's a nice gesture but there are other
more months who might want to keep their
families most valuable possession Joris
cousin Leanna could do some work with
Valyrian steel but John is the hero and
must have his magic sword down at
Winterfell are you
accuses Sansa of helping the Lannisters
kill their father Ned which isn't true
Sansa repeatedly pleaded for Ned's life
to the Queen to the court and at Ned's
execution which are you saw there is
this letter supporting the Lannisters
that Sansa wrote but Cersei made her
write that Sansa was a child and had no
choice and Sansa tells aiya this but I
adjust attacks answer for being weak and
stupid and goes on again about Sansa's
pretty dresses so I has no real argument
here she's just acting out of anger
neither her childhood frustrations with
pretty Sansa her anger is understandable
but it's a huge lack of perspective to
be threatening Sansa for liaison with
Lannisters years ago when there are
actual Lannisters out there right now
who want to kill the Starks Cersei is
the real enemy as I have forgotten her
plan to kill the Queen her criticism of
Sansa is also totally hypocritical given
that aya served Tywin Lannister in
season two so I is acting really
irrationally in this scene which
perfectly plays in to Peter's plan he
planted santa's letter to turn Arya
against her and now Sansa is coming to
Littlefinger for help just as he planned
he subtly suggests that Sansa not John
should rule the north which seems to be
paid his overall goal he wants Sansa to
rule the kingdom and he wants to rule
Sansa but first he has to deal with Arya
Littlefinger suggests that Sansa used
Brienne to deal with iya somehow but
it's not clear exactly what he's
suggesting does he think Brienne would
imprison or kill Arya because that
doesn't seem likely well maybe he wants
to send Brienne away so that she can't
protect Arya
whatever he's getting at Sansa does end
up sending Brienne south to represent
her at the meeting with Cersei it makes
sense that Sansa needs someone she
trusts at the meeting but as Brienne
points out it's very risky for Sansa to
send away her most loyal protector at
this dangerous time especially
considering in the very next scene Arya
confronts Sansa again and this time our
hands an actual argument she suggests
that Sansa wants to
undermine John and ruled the north
herself this is what Littlefinger was
hinting at and Sansa might actually kind
of want her she has disagreed with some
of John's decisions she is proud of her
role in the Battle of the bastards and
she does seem to believe Peter saying
that she's a good ruler
so while Sansa would probably never
actually betray John part of her deep
down might want to and ayah with her
lying game training might see this so it
almost makes sense
for aya too precious answer to deter her
from betraying John but pointing a knife
at her sister and threatening to kill
her and wear her face is pretty extreme
Aya's motivation is again far more
personal than strategic
Kasana asks about is collection of faces
which i uses to take on magic disguises
aya says that the faces make her feel
empowered to take on whatever identity
she wants without being forced into
gender roles which is not how the
faceless men are meant to work they are
a cult who make you give up your
identity and become no one to serve the
god of death but Anya is using their
powerful magic for her own personal
gratification she's got great power but
no responsibility so instead of using
her magic wisely she uses it to threaten
her sister for being mean to her years
ago on the one hand this kind of fits
the fame of our rejecting the rules of
the faceless men and choosing instead to
wreak revenge on whoever she doesn't
like at the time but this also goes
against our theme of returning to a
stark identity and family which is one
of the deepest parts of her arc so this
whole conflict between aya and Sansa
feels really contrived but it may end
soon
Brown hinted earlier that he knows
things about Peters schemes if he
reveals Littlefinger's betrayals the
stark girls could bond again over
bringing justice to their true enemy
back beyond the wall torment talks [ __ ]
with the hound and mentions Brienne
Brienne almost killed the Hound back in
season 4 but torment has fallen in love
with her a relationship between a
wildling and a high bond southern lady
could potentially be a big deal in the
books a Lascar stark marries a wildling
leader which hole
solidify the pace between wildlings and
the north
maybe torment and Brienne could do
something similar berrak speaks with
john and says he doesn't look much like
his father so he must look more like his
mother
what barrack is saying is that John
doesn't look like Ned but we know that
John's real father is actually Rhaegar
Targaryen and it's true that John
doesn't look like him with his blond
hair and purple eyes John looks more
like his mother Liana there have been so
many hints this season about John's real
parents will surely get more on this
mystery sometime soon The Hound sees a
mountain that fits the vision he saw in
Episode one a mountain that looks like
an arrowhead this same mountain was also
visible in bronze vision of the creation
of the White Walkers which means that
all this is taking place near the same
spot where the night King was born
there's also symbolism in the Hound
looking at a mountain because his hated
brother Gregor is called the mountain
some still hope that the two might fight
at Dragonstone Danny talks to Tyrion
about heroes she names Drogo Jorah and
Daario who are all brave men but are
they really heroes Drogo was a brutal
warlord who attacked innocent villages
to kill enslave and rape their people
Jorah was a slaver who fled justice and
spied on Daenerys Daario is a mercenary
who betrayed his own comrades and
advises Dany to mass murder by most
standards these guys are no heroes but
that's the thing about Game of Thrones
some of the good guys are badder than
the actual bad guys of other shows Dany
does name one true hero though Jon Snow
who almost always fights for what's
right heroes like him Danny says get
themselves killed which in John's case
is truer than Danny knows they talk
about Cersei who Tyrion expects will set
a trap for Daenerys when they meet at
King's Landing
so Tyrion says they'll protect Dany by
threatening to burn the city if so she
tries anything but they do want to avoid
deceit and murder it's interesting that
in previous times when Danny met enemies
she happily used to Satan murder she
betrayed and slayed slavers and slaves
alike at a stupor
but if Danny wants her rule of Westeros
to last longer than a rule of murine she
needs people to trust her
Tyrion raises the question of succession
who will rule after Danny dies normally
it would be the rulers child but Danny
has no children and apparently never
will because in book one Miri Mazda
tells Danny that she's infertile and
Danny never got pregnant by Dario so it
seems probably true so what happens to
the realm after Danny dies Danny doesn't
want to talk about it she gets prickly
when Tyrion talks about her death a bit
like a certain author we all love but
Danny has got to work out something
so Tyrion mentions democracy as a
possible way for Westeros to choose
their next ruler just as the Ironborn
and the Nights Watch vote for their
leaders this is the first real glimpse
we've gotten of what breaking the wheel
might actually mean to Daenerys and it
seems she's serious about changing the
politics in society of Westeros beyond
the wall Jon's men are attacked by a
zombie bear which kills some red Jets
and savages Thoreau's Barrack sets the
bearer light which doesn't kill it for
some reason
normally fire kills zombies good and the
fire makes the Hound too afraid to
attack the back is the Hound scared of
fire because of his burn but finally
Jorah kills the bear with a dragon glass
dagger in the books
dragonglass doesn't seem to hurt zombies
it only kills the White Walkers but in
the show dragonglass kills both so the
bear goes down Thoris seems pretty
relaxed about the hole in his chest he
takes a swig of drink and keeps on
walking leaving those poor nameless
wildlings in the snow in this show
there's nothing more deadly than having
no dialogue Thoros and Jorah talk about
the siege of Pyke battle ten years ago
when forest led a charge against the
Ironborn waving his flaming sword like
some kind of god but Thoris reveals that
he wasn't really brave
he was just blackout drunk which is
another of those moments in Thrones
which questions the glory of war
eventually the men see a small group of
zombies led by a white Walker maybe
these guys are scouting or hunting for
benjin John's men attacked the dead and
when John kills the Walker
the zombies fall except for one
apparently zombies die when you kill the
Walker that raised them this one zombie
that survived must have been raised by a
different Walker this is important
information because it means that the
whole army of the dead could be
destroyed if they can just kill the
white walkers which John seems to be
getting good at also if we assumed the
night King created the other white
walkers through this baby changing
process maybe killing just the night
king would kill all the other walkers as
well as all the zombies so this whole
war could possibly end with just one
swing of John's sword the problem now
though is that they're captive zombies
screams for help and the entire army of
the Dead starts chasing John's men John
chooses this moment to get Kendra to
send a message for help to Daenerys
which is really bad timing John always
knew that they were facing danger why
not ask Danny for help before they're
just about to be killed why not just
have Danny come along in the first place
and save them all this walking but John
runs to a convenient island on a
convenient lake which is just
conveniently frozen enough for John to
cross but not frozen enough to let the
dead Gendry marathons to Eastwatch and
sends a raven the thousand miles down to
Dragonstone so that Danny can fly the
thousand miles north to save them which
would take days days of John's men
freezing eating and sleeping on that
island and all the while the night king
and the dead just stand and watch which
is pretty weird even if they come across
the water they could just throw spears
or shoot arrows or throw rocks at John
right but the dead are patient they
waited about 8,000 years since the last
long night so maybe they might as well
wait a few days for the ice to freeze
and the walkers do seem to enjoy toying
with people in book one they stand in a
circle and watch while a walker fights
Waymar Royce laughing and mocking him so
watching John freeze and staff might be
their idea of entertainment Thoros dies
of his wounds and the men hold little
funeral for him in book 4 Thoreau says
it does not matter how a man begins but
how he ends Thoreau's began this story
has a fat drunk failure of a priest but
he dies as a warrior fighting for life
against the dead
check out the thoris video for more on
this character The Hound like an idiot
throws a rock that shows the lake as
frozen
so the dead start to attack John's men
John uses Valyrian steel berrak as his
flaming sword and torment and Jorah and
Sandor use dragonglass weapons so
they've got exactly the right tools to
counter the dead but there are a lot of
them though so [ __ ] gets pretty real
before the inevitable drug on ex machina
arrives Dany swoops in with her dragons
and burns the dead a bit like that dream
in book 3 but as she rescues John's men
the night King activates his trap card
and throws an ice spear that hits
Danny's dragon Viserion killing one of
the only three dragons alive in Westeros
the king has three Spears for Danny's
three dragons almost as though he knew
that they were coming so some people
theorize that this whole thing was a
trap but it's not clear how the night
king would know that Danny's dragons
exist let alone that Danny would come
save John at this time and place Danny
didn't even know she would come until
like a day ago so unless the night king
is straight-up psychic like bran the
trap idea doesn't seem likely
after Vissarion dies Jon decides not to
immediately get on dragon and fly away
but instead to kill some more zombies
and take a dip in the lake so Danny
leaves without him if Danny had decided
instead to attack the night king to burn
him or crash a dragon into him she could
have ended this whole war there and then
but she flees and leaves her child
Viserion dead in the lake Jon survives
because at this point falling into water
is practically a guarantee that a
character will live then he faces the
army of the Dead and prepares to die her
be like he did at the Battle of the
bastards you'd think that after dying
and being reborn John would have learned
to stop throwing himself into such
impossibly dangerous situations but it
seems like he's now decided that he can
take as many risks as he likes and who
always survived because somehow he
always does
Benjen saves him at the last minute and
John gets away again one of the moments
that defined Game of Thrones season 1
was the death of Ned Stark which showed
that when good guys make mistakes they
may die in season 3 Robb and Catelyn
made mistakes and they died but by
rescuing John from certain death over
and over and over by saving Jaime and
saving Arya it takes away the tension
and drama every time this happens in
this story we care less Jon's reunion
with benjin is one of the most
long-awaited moments in the series four
years five books and seven seasons Jon
has been hoping to see his uncle again
and in the books there are hints that
benjin knows secrets about John's birth
he was involved in the knight of the
Laughing tree incident which may have
led to John's parents hooking up go
watch that video but in the show there's
no time for that detail benjin turns up
says hi I'm a zombie goodbye and decides
he'd rather die than share a horse with
his nephew it does feel a bit
anticlimactic but there is powerful
simplier inventions death benjin has
apparently been surviving in the north
on his own as a zombie man for years and
years
he's probably suffered in ways that we
can't imagine but he kept on fighting
all this time until he got the chance to
do something noble saving Jon before
letting go he was ready to die and ended
it on his terms
so the reunion is a bit janky but there
is some meaning here The Hound carries
the captive zombie through the wall the
way this seems to work is that the magic
of the wall stops the dead gang through
uninvited but the dead can pass through
the wall if they're carried by the
living like with o'the orange jaffa
flowers in season one that being the
case you'd think that benjin could have
crossed the wall if someone just carried
him but he's not an ordinary zombie so
maybe he works differently either way
the heroes have succeeded in their
insane plot to capture zombie hopefully
it'll be worth it
Dany stands on the wall and waits for
Jon oh maybe she's hoping for a dragon
the dragon doesn't come but John does
collapsed on his horse just like he
Ward's in season 3
Danny says his chest unlearned that he
really was stabbed in the heart and that
he's been keeping up with his situps
when he wakes John says he's sorry about
the death of her dragon Danny did say
that her dragons are the only children
she'll ever have but some people
speculate that the death of Viserion
might allow Danny to have kids again
because Danny's infertility seems to be
a sort of a curse for meri Mazda who
once said that only death can pay for
life may be the death of a dragon will
allow Danny to make life again Danny and
John having children might well beyond
the cuts from all the talk of kids and
succession in this episode and from the
way John and Danny are looking at each
other lately even though they are aren't
and nephew in fact Judah generations of
Rail inbreeding this is like super
incest between John and Danny
but regardless John says he'll kneel to
Danny and make her his queen finally
forming a great alliance to face the
dead
meanwhile the dead pull Viserion out of
the lake like ants pulling a worm some
people have questioned how the dead got
these chains but the walkers have been
around for thousands of years it's
plausible enough that they found some
chains from a ship or a merchant or that
scythe at some point so they pull out
the dragon and the night King raises it
as a zombie a blue-eyes White Dragon
since the night King turns the dragon by
touching it it seems possible that this
dragon is now more like a white Walker
than just a regular zombie like how the
night king changed that baby that baby
was alive though while Vissarion is dead
so there's lots of uncertainty about
what sort of powers the dead dragon will
have and will it breathe fire seems
unlikely when fire kills zombies maybe
it'll breathe Frost like an ice dragon
which is a whole other thing a dragon
that's made out of ice whatever the
specifics zombie dragons are really bad
news this is NK getting nukes and they
will use it no one is safe and Danny and
John must bring fire and fury to stop
the dead in this episode berrak says
that the enemy is death and maybe we
don't need to understand any more than
that it's like beric is telling
the audience but we don't need to
understand how John survived on that
island for days or why the night King
stood and watched we don't need to
understand why aiya suddenly turned on
our sister or how John survives again
and again or how so sees rain works
politically and maybe we don't need our
understand but Game of Thrones at its
best isn't just about battles and
dragons it's complex politics and human
drama that makes you think David and Dan
do an amazing job of adapting a story
that George Martin wrote to be
unadaptable and at this point they've
even run out of books to adapt but
hopefully these last seasons of Thrones
can conclude the story without losing
that layer of detail and depth that
makes Thrones unique thanks for watching
thanks to patrons Jessie deal Charlie
Fox Hannah Hurst Nicola Thompson Bruno's
Ozzy she'll Belle and J Poppa lopoliths
she is
you